i'm patrick david welcome to the iced
coffee podcast and my guess is this
podcast has made roughly a hundred and
ninety three thousand dollars okay not
terrible very good it's pretty good yeah
it's close it's close two hundred and
forty six thousand
fifty yeah you're within the ballpark
yeah that's good this is good well thank
you so much for being able to make it
this morning this is i have to say an
honor to be
on a video with you because i've watched
you now for probably no joke six years
when i first started making youtube
videos you were one of the very
few people on youtube who's making
business content it just didn't exist
you ty grant dave ramsey i think that
was it so
you're crushing everybody by the way so
great job for what you guys are doing
because your content is oh thanks
absolutely amazing thank you so much
i want to hear about your story and just
for for people that don't know who you
are how did you make your money so uh a
story you want me to tell you my story
or how i made my money both okay so born
and raised in iran i lived there ten
years uh six weeks after khomeini died
we escaped we went to germany at a
refugee camp i lived there for about a
year and a half then i came to the
states
and uh moved to glendale california
lived there for about six years school
wasn't really for me i had a 1.8 gpa i
went to the army fort campbell kentucky
hunter first airborne
i got out i wanted to be a bodybuilder
that was kind of my route i was going to
be a middle eastern arnold win a mr
olympia going to hollywood mary kennedy
wanted to be a governor that was kind of
like the vision and then i met a girl
named jamir at venice beach who worked
at morgan stanley dean witter she
introduced me to morgan stanley dean
witter i applied
got a job a day before 9 11 with morgan
glendale got my series 766 31 26 life in
hell that was my life that's the
direction i went i went to transamerica
i was there for seven and a half years
and then started my own company october
of 09 php agency and we grew that from
66 agents to
you know we're putting an event here at
the mgm grand arena we're probably gonna
have 12 to 13 000 people here we have 20
000 agents nationwide so my money was
made through insurance
financial services investments and then
accidentally start a youtube channel
turns into media turns into a consultant
company and it is what it is today great
story and just to clear the air so
because people are going to be very
confused because we're not in our usual
studio where exactly are we
12 to 13 000 yeah so we are at mgm grand
arena so the big tyson fights michael
jackson jay-z connor mayweather drake
beyonce everybody's put a concert here
there's a place i'll walk you from the
back
and you'll see the vip where they stay
at you got to get a sneak peek of that
and you'll see the wall of fame you know
the hall of fame where all these guys
performed here but yeah this is the mgm
grand arena takes you know this event
that we're putting together the next
four or five days
six million give or take a budget to put
an event together like this and we're
gonna have shaq here friday we're gonna
have nelly open up with a concert we're
gonna have penn and teller performing
we'll have laila ali here we'll have
kurt warner here that's steven we're
putting together this is just for the
insurance company this is your insurance
company the one i started yeah the
purpose of this what is the purpose of
this it's an annual convention
recognition training announcements
uh this is a very special event because
we just got partnered up acquired by
integrity marketing group and we'll be
making that announcement here they'll be
hearing from the new folks that are it's
a very important meeting that we do but
it's once a year recognition competition
training inspiration all of that happens
here next few days how important is that
for your employees and the people that
work with you to have this sort of
recognition and to have an event like
this where they all come together in one
place so so recognition is why any one
of us does what we do right i mean if
you look at the data analytics what are
you looking for how to improve you want
to compete you want to put up better
numbers how can we get better we have
more viewership we're staying relevant
it's consistent the numbers here so
recognizing w-2 folks is different than
1099 a sales organization does not exist
or thrive without any form of
recognition you take any sales
commission type of an environment you
have to have a form of competition
recognition to reward the people because
the whole concept of capitalism is what
okay so we're here doing this interview
i'm putting the event together right now
i've been up since god knows what time
talking to all the av guys this morning
i don't have to do this meeting you
don't have to do this meeting you got to
plan plenty of money in the bank as a
young guy you're doing great for
yourself living in a beautiful home
you've been successful and so why do you
choose to do this why do i choose to do
this why not take today off why not you
take today off why travel 6 30 in the
morning today after your flight that
canceled last night at 11 o'clock you
could have made a great excuse and
stayed at washington state nobody would
have said it
that's a great point but the point is we
all compete
and the form of competing is we're
thriving to accomplish something that's
we feel proud of to share with our
family with our kids with our parents
with our competitors with our folks that
we're doing business with so recognition
is a big part of running a sales
organization how do you motivate people
because i feel like everyone is
different let's say one person might not
be motivated by money yeah how do you
how do you encourage people from your
perspective you have any kids i don't
okay so i got four of them uh uh and
they're all different okay i was just
with them this morning they read a book
this morning every day they're required
to read 20 pages of from the moment
you're a kid in the david family you
turn six you got to read 20 pages a day
okay and that's been the case for every
one of my kids since they and by the way
that includes holidays sundays it
doesn't matter what it is the currency
in our house is reading you read you get
whatever you want so yesterday i'll give
you an idea where chino poblano a
restaurant here i go to all the time
it's not a high ranking restaurant it's
a jose andres restaurant it's a fusion
between mexican food and chinese food so
we go there mario looks at the poster
says who is that that's frida then he
looks at dylan and
patrick and says what do you know about
frida well let me tell you this who was
she married to a guy named diego what
happened to her lex did you know she had
a amputee leg did you and they start
talking i'm like how do you know all
this stuff well that you made us read
the book freedom right so currency in us
in our house is that but when i talk to
the kids
each of them are not driven by the same
thing my middle son will play sports all
day long loves it my oldest son went and
made his first movie two weeks ago three
weeks ago and he loves it 10 years old
right it's a short film he made i can't
drive my son the older one
on playing baseball one day we're
sitting outside we're throwing the ball
and i said listen we got to throw the
ball for 20 minutes and he throws the
ball so good the oldest and i say to him
i said man you're great at baseball he
says yeah but i don't like it
so i keep encouraging him oh dylan tico
you throw the ball so good he says yeah
but i don't like it i keep telling him
man such a great pitch
my hand hurts it was great he says that
can i just talk to you real quick he
says yes 10 year old kid tells me this
he says dad no matter how much you want
me to play baseball i don't like
baseball okay so motivating folks
is very different
for everybody the first thing you do to
motivate anybody is asking questions are
you single are you driven by
fame money success mom dad ship on the
shoulder a teacher said you couldn't do
it an ex broke up with you
a friend backstabbed you
a spiritual connection that you want to
make god proud a
mom left you dad left you that say you
will never amount to anything you have
this vision of what kind of a life you
want to the more inventory and content i
get from the individual the more you can
drive them but if you're trying to
motivate him the same way to motivate
alex versus motivating you
it's gonna be a uh you will not succeed
so first gather content
then based on that paint a picture of
what life could look like and then break
it down on what needs to be done for
that to become a reality and then ask
are you okay if this never becomes a
reality i'm not well then are you
willing to pay the price for this to
become a reality yes well now let's go
because it's going to be hard so that
formula is generally what we use what
about for you i mean what drives you
every day you do a lot yeah so you know
for me you got to realize i'm born in a
very weird family my mother's they were
communists my dad they were imperialists
and born and raised in iran you know you
don't have a lot when my dylan was
asking me a question last week he says
dad what was your dream when you were my
age i said what's yours he says you know
what mine is
football baseball et cetera okay cool so
when i was your age at eight years old i
had one dream the dream was to come to
america that's all it was i didn't have
a dream of being a doctor
i didn't have a dream of being an
engineer realtor purely come to america
well that dream became a reality when we
came to the states and then
for the longest time with my life i'm
just going women bodybuilding partying
military it's great that that's my life
and then one day i get out and i'm i'm
partying and my dad has a heart attack
and i go to the hospital my dad is
laying there at ucla medical center in
la and he's being mistreated in a way
where they're not coming and servicing
him he's pressing a button they're not
coming for 20 minutes i go out there so
what are you guys doing my dad's asking
for excuse me who are you i said i'm his
son he says call security they kick me
out and the lady said the most magical
thing she says you have no say at how we
treat your dad here this is a government
paid hospital you don't pay it here
taxpayers are paying for this it hit me
i said okay no problem this is what it
is i went in the car i sat in the car my
ford focus i said this will never happen
again so for me it's changed it was
making my mom and dad proud my dad
wanted to go to hawaii i took him to
hawaii i
sent my sister to their honeymoon
because they couldn't go to their
honeymoon it was a lot of that then it
was about the car the travel the
speaking the personal pride accolades
all that stuff
and then you make money 2008 at this
point i got money in the bank i'm in my
late 20s i'm doing good in the insurance
business i'm known
uh i'm not creating content it's a very
private small industry i'm a part of and
suddenly i'm sitting there saying okay
what's next you're not going to do it
just for money if it's for money you'll
slow down if if it's just for a house
you'll slow down if it's for another
watch you'll slow down these things are
not exciting but first we got to thank
our sponsor ftxus as you probably have
noticed cryptocurrency prices are down
quite a bit from their peak and now
could be a time to buy in well below
where prices were just about six months
ago and ftx us wants to help they're
used by millions of users including us
to buy sell track and trade both crypto
and to nfts all in one place with fees
that are up to 85 percent lower than the
top competitors and jack hates fees
don't you know what i think about fees
you hate them i hate fees man they make
me sick and that's exactly why we
recommend you guys check out ftx with
that link down below yeah and jack i'll
show you exactly how easy it is all you
have to do is go and select what you
want to buy how much of it you want to
buy how often you want to buy it and
then you swipe right and you're done and
by the way every trade you make over ten
dollars gives you free crypto gram can't
know this but they actually just
launched ftx stocks so now it's an app
where you can trade crypto and nfts and
stocks all in one place it's going to be
absolutely amazing definitely check it
out with that link down below and they
also recently spent 250 million dollars
expanding their equity trading
infrastructure to ensure that even their
stock trades don't have fees again the
link is down below in the description
enjoy thank you guys so much and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast i called all my advisors
and i uh had meetings with them these
are all folks that are 30 years older
than i said i said listen i'm at a phase
of my life where i'm very my my fuse is
short i got to figure out what i want to
do next but i don't know yet what should
i do i want to commit to something for
20 years and then i went and met
george will at santa monica uh what's
that hotel myrmar hotel which you guys
lived close to before
and i went and met with george will and
all these other guys that were there and
he says why don't you go study why so
many people come to america from other
countries why does america lead the
world in you know immigration why does
america have 40 million why do we only
say american dream why do we not say
russian dream why is there no such thing
as a chinese dream why is there no such
thing as the iranian dream why is there
only the american dream why why is
america
forexing number two in immigration why
is that go study that and share that
with the world for the rest of your life
i said great i left and so the obsession
came once that obsession came here i
said this is what i'm going to be doing
for the rest of my life and so
everything with today with what's going
on in the economy i think we have missed
the mark on hero making machine
i would much rather have my guys my kids
look up to a guy like you who's going
out there independently winning making
money becoming somebody that we don't
need to support you he doesn't need to
support you taxpayers don't need to
support you you're taking care of your
family you're educating people we need
to
clarify who the real hero is the media
is making the wrong people into heroes
and so for us it's to compete having
four kids you gotta you gotta build a
media company
and tell the story the way you feel is
right because uh i think that direction
of turning the right people into heroes
we've missed the mark the last few years
how is having kids change your
perspective at what age were you when
you started having i i was 32 when i had
my first one
uh and you got to realize i love kids if
i could have 20 kids we just got married
late and my wife is not comfortable
having more kids we were supposed to
have twins one of them didn't make it so
we made a decision this is we got four
right now decision was to have five we
were going to have five one didn't make
it we got four we're very happy but what
do kids do so think about uh jordan
peterson said something very interesting
he says men will not really uh
lose the ability to be selfish until you
have a kid i'm prep you know
not necessarily saying it specifically
the way he said it but once you have a
kid something changes about you
because everything's about you know i'm
gonna go do this and yeah you love your
wife but you love your wife in a
different way than you love your mom in
a different way than you love your dad
in a different way than you love your
you know brother or sister than the way
you love your best friend and the way
you love your career than the way you
love your kid i've experienced all those
loves it's a very very different love
for your kid now having said that
somebody's gonna watch us and say i'm
gonna go make a baby tonight okay
i highly discouraged of doing that
because before you have a kid you have
to also know you can't be it doesn't
take a lot to make a kid it takes a lot
to raise a kid we have shaq here so
shaq's story is an interesting one with
his father
where
his biological father wasn't there he
went to jail when he was born so
this other gentleman comes in who helps
raise him and there's a lot of great
stories about the way his father raised
them one time uh shaka caught drinking
beer at 13 years old so his dad finds
out he's drinking beer so he goes to his
dad says you want to drink beer he says
he says no i'm just having beard that he
says no problem come with me
he has him drink
12 beers that night he says i hated it
so much i never touched beer ever again
i couldn't stand it now whether he had a
backfire i mean it is what that could
backfire i loved it i had so much fun
since then
but the point is you hear these stories
and you say okay at least his father
whether you want to call it stepfather
or not he was committed to wanting to
raise leaders you have to love raising
leaders if that's not something that you
value and it's not a dream of yours
don't have kids but you know the jewish
proverb says
there's three things every man should do
okay plant a tree
write a book have a son
okay because all those three outlive you
when you write a book if you write a
good book people gonna read it when
you're dead when you plant a tree if you
do it right it's going to outlive you
when you have a sun it's going to
outlive you and your legacy continues so
it's a very different dynamic
you officially are in two places at the
same time it's where you are and it's
wherever your kid is at if you got two
kids three different places at the same
time
you're always thinking but it's a
different dynamic that's for sure so i
have a friend alex hormozy we had him on
the podcast and he said he would have a
hard time having a kid because what if
his kid didn't turn out to be the type
of man that he would want his kid to be
okay so great question so let's talk
about that we're on a flight yesterday
and in our family what we do is we
debate we like debate so i'll tell the
kids who's better marvel or avengers one
kid will say oh definitely marvel and
the other kid will say adventure i said
let's debate it why do you think and
we'll debate for 30 minutes so yesterday
we're flying out here myself my wife uh
sam mario and tom and the kids and we
started debate so let me ask you a
question my sons are sitting there 10
and 8. i said would you rather marry a
girl who you're crazy about her
more
than she's for you or would you rather
marry a girl
who
she's more crazy about you
yeah you should have seen what happened
first of all no joke a couple of the
people on the flight i won't mention
started crying an hour and a half later
because it's an emotional conversation
because you go deeper and deeper and
deeper because the risk is if you love
her more and she doesn't love you as
much what if she gets bored but then the
risk is what if you marry somebody that
she loves you more but you get bored
what if you then go bored and do
something so there's a risk so here's a
moral of the story to alex alex is an
absolute start of a guy and i think
i think he's a
doing a phenomenal job for society with
the message he's given and it's a
different kind of a message but it's
crystal clear a great teacher he's doing
a very good job i think that guy's going
to be a giant in the content creation
he's already doing great for business
but in content creation but let me make
the point to with what he said
everything in life is a risk
you choose to get married
it's a risk
you choose to stay single it's a risk
you choose to have kids you're taking a
risk you choose to not have kids you're
taking a risk there isn't anything in
life you do that's not a risk i can
choose
to have been a i could have chosen to
have been a bachelor
living in a 40 million dollar penthouse
in in miami and had different girls
coming every night but then i asked the
question i said so what will my tuesday
night look like
what will my weekend look like what will
my friday night look like at 43 what am
i doing okay cool
one weekend you do it at school five
girls 10 girls 20 girls 30 girls then
what at what like what are you chasing
are you trying to compete with will
chamberlain you're going after war and
betty what record are you trying to
break and then what if you get that
record are they going to put a frame in
a hall of fame saying 5 293 different
who cares about that only guys in their
20s may care about that or some other
people may care about that but some
people may care for that that's still a
risk it's a lonely life eventually okay
if you end up in that space but i've
said this as well when it comes down to
marriage you get married if you want to
have kids your family will benefit more
if you're married
instead of not being married and there's
a very clear argument for not having
kids especially today it's a very big
risk for having kids today because if
you don't have money say you have a
certain set of values like he's not in
risk you know but certain people will be
in risk say you have certain values that
you want to teach your kids but you
can't send your kids to a private school
your kids will go to public school what
happens if your kids go to public so how
much control and influence do you have
over what those teachers eight hours a
day will teach your kids you have this
much influence okay because you ain't
paying for it taxpayers are paying for
it right there is massive massive risk
you bring this kid here
you raise them you feed them you finance
them and then other people shape their
mindset that's a massive risk so for me
the argument of not having kids if you
don't have the money to put them in a
private school that teaches the values
and principles that you want to teach i
fully understand that argument but the
idea for alex who can afford to have 50
kids himself to say i don't want to have
kids because what if that kid turns out
bad he's right it's going to that's why
you don't have only one kid alex you
have five kids
and then you play the odds game you have
no idea
that's why macy says she wants two kids
she wants two yeah she really say that
yeah she's like what if one it's like
something that happens yeah
i know she's like half joking because
i've always wanted one i'm an only child
uh you know i have a half sister but
she's way older than me so i grew up
just by myself and i've always wanted
like i loved that attention and focus so
i've always wanted one but she's grown
up in a family of you know two siblings
so it's kind of interesting you said
that you know the only thing about
having one is
um i have a friend
who's the only child and her parents run
the business and they raised her well
she went and became a doctor
and then one day
the parents built this business that's
220 million a year one day she sits down
with her husband and tells her parents
look guys you better take care of this
company because it's our business
anyways
so the parents come down and they say
how do i handle this kid she already
thinks it's their business i said that's
the price of having one kid it's too
much of a risk now your parents got
lucky for having a guy like yeah there
is a benefit but i think three's a good
number okay i think three you know why
three
so i read a story about billy graham one
time which was great he says look he
says there was an error where these
pastors were traveling on their own and
they're going and giving talks and these
young girls will be like oh my god that
pastor is such a great speaker and they
would go to pastor's room and pastor
would sin right after you just gave a
great message so pastor said moving
forward we're only going to travel with
twos we're not going to go with
one we'll room up with two of us
together so these pastors go and what
they notice is if one pastor can sell
the other one on doing something and not
telling anybody they can generally do
something bad then they say no we have
to travel in three because in three at
least one person is going to say guys
i'm not in it so one is going to make
the other one for not doing anything
dumb so if you have three kids say two
of the kids convince each other to do
something stupid one of the kids going
to say guys i don't want to do that
because that's going to be
and then if there's four there's two
people that can agree on this and
there's two people and then you have
good debate so that's a good show that's
a great thought patrick but all of a
sudden we're back in our office and we
want to say thank you to our sponsor
wealthfront wealthfront is a saving and
investing app that can help you earn
more on your money and start building
wealth for your future if you're keeping
cash anywhere that's not paying you a
high interest rate you really gotta
reconsider that's because the
wealthfront cash account gives everyone
a two percent apy interest rate which is
20 times what traditional banks pay and
unlike other saving options you'll
always have access to your money since
they have unlimited free transfers no
account fees and free access to over 19
000 atms wealthfront only takes a few
minutes to sign up and you can start
earning two percent apy immediately and
if you start now you'll get a free 50
bonus with a 500 deposit there are
already nearly half a million people
using wealthfront to save more earn more
and build long-term wealth so why wait
so earn two percent in your cash today
by visiting wealthfront.com
ich the link is down below in the
description or again it's
wealthfront.com
ich and honestly they've been a company
that i've been personally using for a
few years now and at two percent
interest it's pretty much higher than
almost every other option out there so i
would highly recommend them this
no-brainer good news has been a paid
endorsement by wealthfront thank you so
much wealthfront once again link down
below and back to the podcast what are
your thoughts on homeschooling because
we had a very uh
dicey conversation with houston that got
a lot of views on instagram houston is
very adamant about homeschooling what
are your thoughts on that okay so
what was dicey about it i'm curious what
what lecture he said something similar
to what you said where if you bring a
kid to public school you don't know what
they're teaching your kid you know the
values that they instill in your kid
yeah even private school he believes
that he could shape their viewpoints in
their mind uh to a way that he believes
is
i don't want to say correct but in a way
that's maybe different
from everyone else okay so what's
controversial about that a lot of people
believe that it was sheltering to the
child that they're not going to have the
social skills to develop and come to
their own thoughts and and experience
the real world because once they're out
there they're not going to be in that
environment where it's safe i'm happy i
was public schooled by the way i'm
public school as well so but but i'll
tell you this so let's talk about
sheltering you don't think you're
sheltered growing up
you don't think you and i were sheltered
to a certain degree yes and no i mean
think about it it's just compared to
what
but sheltering to me it's not even from
the standpoint of your parents
if you're living in america say you're
like you know how you go to i'll go to
alabama and i'm like you know at a place
doing a meeting and i'll go to a
restaurant
hey so
where'd you grow up at right here how
long you been here 28 years what was it
like growing up in alabama you know what
people will say
the famous lion it's the only thing i
know
she was sheltered in alabama right we
are all in a sense sheltered in the city
we grew up in in the state we grew up in
and in the country we grew up in what
you think about iran is based on how the
countries sheltered you to believing
about iran right
what you believe about china or mexico
or brazil or canada everything is a form
of sheltering so there is risk and
you know everybody is a little bit
afraid of the wrong influence getting a
hold of you now eventually here's what
happens the sooner you teach values
later on if this kid wants to go sell
cocaine and go become a drug addict and
do whatever he wants to do or she wants
to do that part's on them you can't
teach the right values and principles
after 18. it's very hard it's not
received the same way as you teach it
early on so the sooner
somebody teaches you the right habits
the sooner you have an edge the later
somebody teaches like for example
insurance industry
if i were to tell you haven't been in
this industry for 21 years that's going
to be 21 years september the people that
gave us the most problems when they came
in were people that came in who left
three other insurance companies and we
would sit there and look at and say why
are we having so many problems with
these guys well they brought bad habits
from another insurance company the
people that we train ourselves we have
the least amount of issues with because
they're learning how to sell the proper
way you know in mortgages and real
estate i don't know if you remember
mortgage and real estate in 08 in 06
a phrase that was going viral was called
creative financing are you familiar with
creative finance okay so you know what
creative financing is creative creative
financing
isn't that when they you like use a
bunch of weird like terms and stuff no
so he knows what it is so creative
financing would be uh how much money you
made last year and you say eighty-two
thousand dollars is that information to
no no no so you wanna get a loan to buy
a house right okay and i would say to
you don't worry about it we'll make a
fake uh 1099 that you made 220 last year
and we'll put in the file don't worry
about it we'll make a fake bank of
america statements wow so that's crazy
there was there was all of that going on
all over the place for creating those oh
six yeah a lot of guys called
loans no income no job yeah no income
that's right it's stated so you could
say whatever you want in the obligation
creative financing was a wink-wink
business model
those guys that got trained in creative
financing wherever they went to next
they brought those habits with them to
the next place if forgery was a normal
habit at that real estate office or
mortgage office you brought into
pharmaceutical sales you bought it in
digital media agency you brought it into
stocks you know it doesn't matter so
that habit continues this if there's a
reason why people hired people away from
jack welch there's a reason why
companies recruited people away from
xerox xerox was known for training their
salespeople better than anybody else if
you got a guy away at 29 30 years old
away from xerox and his first job with
xerox you're doing backflips because
xerox was known for having the best
training if like i came from bally's
bally's was known for having the best
sales training out of everybody so guess
who want to recruit the people from
valleys la fitness 24-hour fitness why
because we were the best trainers we
were trained the right way no
misrepresentation none of that stuff it
was the right way by from the top so
what's the moral the story he's right
homeschooling i won't homeschool because
to me homeschooling not everybody makes
a good teacher where i'm going to have
the time or the ability to have my wife
teach
teaching is not for everybody if you can
have somebody else do the job for
teaching it's great but i support the
idea of people wanting to do
homeschooling today because they're
scared of what's going on with the
marketplace what the kids are being fed
today that is a big risk today when you
have kids
you look at it from a different
perspective look guy asked me today
security ask the the guy that we all
came through here the 70 year old man up
there who
uh is from virginia went to world war
he's seven years i've been here for 50
years him and i are having a
conversation this morning at 6 a.m when
i'm checking out the property we're
talking about uh uh schooling and
stories about you know what the school's
like he says the same thing he said look
i wanted to have my kids be in an
environment where they're learning a
certain values and principles you go to
public nowadays somebody's raising your
kids it's a very very big risk today a
very big risk today very different today
than when i went to school it's a very
different risk today so i fully
understand it but if you don't have the
means you don't have the choice you have
to go through public schools yeah how do
you balance the relationship between
your business and also your wife and how
do you keep that spark between you and
your wife when you're when you're doing
so many things how many hours would you
say you're working per week
so good question i'm non-stop because
i'm running nine businesses today uh and
i'm doing podcasts and i'm creating
content for valuetainment when i get a
chance to
you know end up deals i'm a part of etc
etc but let's talk that's a great
question so a lot of
our relationship today is how we got
married not necessarily today so let me
unpack that for you
our first date we go out
we had known each other for five and a
half years she was dating another guy or
two and i was dating another girl or two
and then finally we were single
and i said who are you looking for and
we went on our first date
the next date we went out and i took her
to borders borders in santa monica right
by the stairs in santa monica which you
guys know the stairs
in santa i took her to borders when
there used to be a borders because
there's not a borders today i bought her
a book on our on our second date it was
called 101 questions to ask before you
get engaged i've done this exercise with
three other girls
at the same time okay not being
promiscuous i'm just doing this exercise
with three other girls because i was at
a phase and i'm looking for a wife i'm
not looking for no more playing around
fooling around i knew i was ready i was
not ready for a long time 28 i was ready
28 29 i was ready
so she reads the book i said you go
through the book i said 55 54 the
questions are important to me i don't
care about the rest but whatever
questions are important to you i'll give
you my answers a week later we meet and
we go through it six hours to go through
these questions questions are how long
can you handle me being away on the road
questions are you know what baggage do
you bring to the table and on the bottom
it says if the person says none run the
questions are how many kids do you want
to have who manages the money what do
you think about prenuptial agreements
what if everything is in there okay
so we went through it
and then i kept asking her for a year
and a half because you need arguments
because the first three to six months of
a relationship is a lie it's all fake
it's hollywood we're acting we're giving
our best we're not giving our words
so i had to learn eventually i'm like
i'm so when you date a lot of people you
learn what you don't want more than what
you do want i definitely don't want this
i can't deal with this i don't want that
i want these five things but i
definitely don't want these 13 things
okay
so
it was less of an act up front this is
who i am you're going to see the best of
me the worst of me
and then when it got to a point where
we're getting married
we sit there there's a moment when
you're talking to your girl that you're
going to get married to and here's what
happens you don't say anything she
doesn't say anything it's all here
you look at her and you say
i think there's a 55 percent chance we
can make this marriage work
you look at and you say
yeah i think it's like a 62 percent
you may look at one you're like i like
her so much when she's so hot but i
think this is a 23 percent one so i'm
definitely not going to go marry this
one and that's internal diet button by
the way everybody does it and and when
people say no
we were for sure it's like oh okay no
problem go wait till people get involved
wait till family needs money and you
have to pay for stuff that you it's your
money and nobody pays you back wait till
kids come and you wait till some stuff
happen you're going to learn marriage is
going to be tested but again going back
to alex's comment about kids no matter
what you do with marriage you're going
to take a risk so going back to your
question with my wife she knows i work
hard
she knows i'm doing what i'm doing
i intentionally built the life around
our house so one of the buildings i
bought is .1 miles away from our house
the other building i bought is one and a
half miles away from the house
our school the kids go to is point six
miles away from the house church is .7
miles because the school and the church
is the same one and the restaurants we
go to so we have lunch
three times a week we have dinner twice
a week and i'm there outside of me being
on the road if i'm on the road i'm on
the road and i'm doing what i'm doing
sunday's is pure family you want to go
on the boat you want to go out there you
want to do this you want to do that no
problem and then
rituals you create for your family
christmas is something we look forward
to and we spend a lot of our resources
for christmas it's very important it's a
time where we get together and we can
only be around people that we enjoy
their companies for four or five days
not enjoy their companies for two hours
we want five day your company people you
enjoy
and then you start adding new rituals
new traditions to your family and that
increases the chances and hopefully if
the people around you are the right
people you'll you'll increase the chance
of making your marriage work but keep
this in mind
i got a call the other day from a guy
that i never thought was going to get a
divorce
never i mean this is a guy like think
about who you know
that you say that couple never they're
gonna be together that kind of a guy
calls me and i said what happened the
guy is a money guy he's a 20 million
dollar guy
he makes money they have a kid together
and she just woke up one day and she
says i want to go back with my guy from
high school and he's single now and i
can't stop thinking about him
woke up left him she's an absolute great
girl from a great family there is
nothing about her track record that you
could say well that one thing nothing
he's a stud
but that just happened
so what's the concern you know somebody
listens to that story and says that's
exactly why i'm not getting married no
the moral the story is people change
you're not god i can't change you you
can't change me we have to take risks
and marriage is the ultimate risk it's
the biggest risk you're taking no
startup company when i risked all my
money was as big of a risk as getting
married and so a lot of times we don't
talk openly like this if you talk to
people in church it's all like but you
have to make it work that's not true i'm
not from that school of thought because
both people have to do their part what
if i'm doing all the work and the other
one doesn't want to do it and i have to
sit there and go through that process
all the time i think we have to openly
and men we don't have too many
conversations like this where we talk
about our insecurities and all these
fears that we have the more we have
these talks and then eventually goes to
the point where look at the end of the
day there is a risk and you make a
decision do you want to do it or not i
don't want to do it no problem i do want
to do it great take the risk it's worthy
of a risk what are your thoughts on
prenups i'm all for it do you ever
prenup absolutely i'm all for it i think
you need to have it uh and let me tell
you what what it did to our relationship
when we have a prenup so do you have one
yourself or i do okay so let me tell you
what it did for us so here's what
happened family calls
uh hey babe such and such happened with
my mother's
cousins
nephews wife whoever it is and i want to
build this guy i need eight thousand
dollars here's eight thousand dollars
babe and you go to work and you're kind
of bitter at your wife you're like i
don't even know who this person is why
the hell are we bailing this person at 8
000
hey babe you know this person died and
we kind of have to help with the funeral
final expense they don't have any money
eighteen thousand dollars
okay here's eighteen thousand dollars
when those things happen two three four
five times you're eventually a little
bit annoyed
she says i want to buy that new chanel
purse
how much babe well it's up a little bit
twelve thousand dollars
okay go buy the chanel purse somebody
may say what's wrong with that what's
wrong with this no problem everybody has
this different set of guidelines i like
where we have
your money my money our money
this is your money you want to buy that
chanel purse buy it with your money
if i want to buy that purse for you i'll
buy it with my money so you know i
bought it with my money it's a form of i
bought it with mine rather than our
money okay if we have something that
we're doing for our kids and ourselves
which is us team us this is our money
if you want to spend 50 000 on your
nephew or your niece you don't even need
to ask me because you're using whose
money your money i notice that minimize
arguments to the point where
no one's being judged no one said why
are you buying that purse why are you
doing this why are you buying that one
no so we go to louis vuitton when this
thing gets set up and she says
uh can i see that purse and can i see
that purse
yes
how much is that 35. how much is that
45. she looks at me i want to buy these
and i look at them like
okay i'm buying it with my money
okay go for it what if she doesn't have
money though what if she is stay-at-home
mom she's not having income but she
wants let's just say the ten thousand
dollars how much do you make
how much do you make
say so give me that scenario but give me
the case study with the husband what
does the husband make gosh let's just
let's just say a million bucks a year if
he makes a million bucks a year and you
know you're going to set up a prenuptial
government to protect you
create a portion an account where you
put money in where she can do whatever
she does without asking you
that's the account so whatever she wants
to buy without ask because i'm in the
business of minimizing arguments so for
example the biggest business issues i've
had in my life
is because i hurried a contract too much
without us getting those additional
three disclaimers in there
that if this happens here's how we exit
this and because we didn't have that it
caused an argument i don't want that so
let's spend a little bit more time with
the contract have your lawyers talk to
our lawyers let's take one more week and
let's see what else we want to add into
this what if it doesn't work between the
two of us they say pat
so let's just say you all of a sudden
wake up one morning you say pat i'm
already worth 20 million we're partners
50 50. i don't want to do anything i
have the right to buy you out at the
market value at the time i can go find
finance and can buy you out but if
that's not in the agreement guess what
you can do but i don't want to sell
i just want to take my profits every
year now i hate you now we have issues
so the same thing with marriage if the
guy is making a million and you're
worried about the money she's spending
put four thousand dollars a month in an
account
this is an account for you this is our
account expenses this is your account do
whatever you want to do with it that
prevents some of the arguments got it
how many times do you feel
alex is clapping over here
how many times do you feel unmotivated
or you feel like you wake up you just i
don't feel like doing anything today or
you feel lost or maybe you feel like
what am i doing this far so you know
that one video
that says um
he says
you know you wake up in the morning and
you say
i still go to the gym because i don't
feel like it we're not the same i feel
like working out every day you know i
don't know if you've seen that one audio
that goes that's picked up on tick tock
i'm not probably not saying it the right
way but here's the point
uh i think that's
a great video to go viral i don't think
that's the reality
because
there's going to be many days i don't
feel like being a dad because of the
responsibilities of changing the diaper
and i got poop on my jacket one day i'm
having a business meeting and i'm
holding my son i have my brand new
lakers gear that i'm wearing all of a
sudden i'm looking at the guys i'm like
why do you guys did you guys step into
something i said look at the bottom of
your shoes they're looking no pat we
didn't step in why does this place smell
so bad
so then all of a sudden like hey pat can
you look at your son i look at my son no
joke
everywhere here oh no i'm trying to
encourage you from not having kids by
the way yeah everywhere here
you see in that moment i'm not feeling
like being a dad yeah yeah i wish it was
in a different place right
you don't feel like running a
media company when this thing keeps
breaking the audio is not being picked
up there's noise in the background and
chips are getting lost and the 30
minutes has gone and you lost best
footage that would have done very well
you don't feel good in that moment so
but the reality of it is
you know in those moments if you truly
have a vision
that's a real vision it's a big vision
and it excites you so much
you have no choice but have to tolerate
chaos
in times of stress and things not going
your way you don't have a choice so when
in that moment some people are like i
just don't feel like doing it today no
problem it's your choice
but if your vision's big you kind of got
to figure out a way to win on days that
you don't feel like it yeah now and you
were mentioning like 2007 2008
you
rethought how you want to go about
business and things you want to do how
did you go about doing that was it was
there a strategy that you used or how
did you think of the next big thing when
you didn't know it yet so when i didn't
know it yet well i didn't know the
bigger vision is what i didn't know
right so for me i got 20 different
motivators under four different
categories that people have one is
individual so you have individual
accomplishments you're going after right
you want to have a degree to be able to
say you went to ucla or you went to penn
you went to wharton that's an individual
accomplishment makes you proud right
individual you want to have a car a
watch clothes you know a house whatever
right that's individual accomplishments
those will run out eventually if it's
just individual then you have one that's
lifestyle lifestyle is purely selfish
stuff that you want the other one is a
purpose you know i want to do something
big and memorable and the last one is
madness madness is
you know
michael jordan is part of madness
community tom brady is part of madness
community connor is part of madness
community i mean you can go down a bunch
of people you know that are part of
madness community you'll know if you're
part of madness community or you're not
part of madness community i read i read
two books one was called hypomanic edge
and the other one was called first rate
madness
why you know some titles like why the
crazy people run the world today you
know whatever it says about people's
personality disorders so for me and oh
wait
i'm so upset because i finally figured
out that money doesn't drive me it's got
to be something more than money
it's got to be something that's a vision
a correcting and injustice
you know that's my belly there's fire in
my belly constantly i can't get rid of
it i've tried a lot because believe me
life would be probably a lot more
peaceful without it because you can take
timeouts and kind of be a little bit
more but you have to be self-aware and
know who you are right so for me i sat
there and i said okay so what are we
doing
is it the big parties is it the house
what is it
no it's not it's much bigger than that
okay how does this feel you know
sometimes you want to buy that watch
let's just say you know the beautiful
watch you have there and let's just say
you go look at the first time and he
said babe i like this watch how much is
it babe
sixty eight thousand dollars
okay
not gonna buy it right now i'm gonna go
and see if i still like it you come back
you look at it again
i still like it you come back two months
later
it doesn't do it for me anymore why buy
it
okay
but if you keep seeing something and it
keeps drawing you in maybe there's
something you got to pay attention to
there right so for me what it caused was
every time i like you know people said
why do you talk politics you were doing
great with valuetainment you talking
entrepreneurship why touch politics you
shouldn't do it you don't do it gary
doesn't do it a lot of you guys don't do
it you guys are just kind of like yeah
your business saying like listen i'll
have you do it man i'll listen to you
yeah
i don't want to take the risk let this
guy do it he's losing followership
because they don't like the fact that
he's given his opinions
and i can take that strategy right and
by the way i know that you guys know i
know that you guys know that why is this
guy touching politics because we know
the space but at the same time
i can't help myself because it's so deep
in my bones
that for me it's more than having 100
million subscribers or 50 million
subscribers we got to have that not
because it's bragging rights we got to
have that because we get to get to more
eyeballs to get the message across right
so the messaging for me changed a little
bit but i i got more and more self-aware
and 08 of myself than i was in o2 and o2
i was just
just wanting to make money i hated being
broke it was a completely different
perspective 08 was like okay you can
actually compete in a marketplace and
you can actually make some real money
but what's bigger than that so that was
the shift that i made got it can you say
about how much you had
when you realized that you didn't want
to focus half a million dollars savings
it's not a lot of money but for me it
was a lot of money that i had in a
weight i feel like i'm kind of going
through something similar right now
where
what i'm doing right now is working so
well i don't want to scale back and i
want to continue with the same
trajectory
and even just another two to three years
of just what i'm doing right now just
maintaining would be
life-changing um but i've been going
through just the last like two years
feeling like i've kind of like
learned as much as i can i've done
already
so many things and i feel like i'm not
growing as a person anymore and i'm
trying to figure out what's next but at
the same time i don't want to give up
what i have or scale back on that
because it's doing so well i feel like
i'd be an idiot to take the the foot off
the gas so to speak um what would be
your advice in that sort of situation
but see that's why people love you
though which you just did right there
that's why people love you no because
you because because that's who you are
you
you just told the world where you are
right now and the book tells you not to
do it that's why they love you that's
why
people want to listen to you you know
look i i will tell you uh uh those who
are not creating content
this is very hard this is not easy
there's only so many times you can come
up with another market crash video
there's only so many things you can say
tell me about it
but you know what they work
but people watch that's the thing
i thought the same thing but i've posted
other videos nobody watches them but
when i post a market crash video
everyone watches it and the like ratios
are the same by the way so it's not like
i'm getting it sure anyway no but i
agree but but but you know uh but here's
a point though what you're doing is not
easy to do
here's the other part you got to be
thinking about
there's two aspects to it there's a
quote that said changed my life it said
sometimes on a way to a dream you get
lost and find a bigger one you're a
little bit lost right now it's kind of
where you are not that you're lost
everybody many people would love to have
your life being lost right now so
there's got to be gratitude and
perspective but you expect more from
yourself and you feel like you can do
more you can contribute more and you can
go to a whole different level um i
love
operating businesses okay so for example
i sit with my goldman guy
and we just had a nice multi-nine-figure
exit four weeks ago so we're sitting
there and
you know he's saying so what do we want
to do with this we're talking to blacks
black you know we're talking all these
guys on what to put a portion of money
in
and he said and i said so how much is
this going to give if we put 50 million
dollars here what is this going to be in
10 years and and don't give me the best
case scenario give me the worst case
he says that 50 could potentially be 100
million 10 years from now
well that doesn't excite me i said
what's the best case is that maybe it's
going to be 125 million so he doesn't
even tell me the 50 is going to be 300
million like over exaggerated he's being
very straight up he's a very
conservative guy
so i said okay cool he says patrick this
is during dinner he said the most
amazing thing to me he says pat no
matter what you put your money in with
us
nothing you're doing right now in your
life is going to make higher returns
than whatever you operate
look what he said whatever you operate
because operating i know how to grow and
scale a business you know how to operate
and grow this this didn't go to where it
did by pure luck you have a system
behind it you're a data guy you're a
numbers guy you're all that stuff right
sooner i found that i'm an operator
that's my game i'm not a guy that's
going to build a 17 billion dollar real
estate portfolio that's not my game i'm
not a guy that's going to go out there
and you know be the next bitcoin guy and
talk i'm a maximal you know i'm not that
guy i'm an operator i like starting
businesses building businesses
you got to take a piece of paper and
write out for yourself
what excites you what are you very good
at
and match those two if what excites you
matches what you're very good at that's
that's that's peaking yeah if if what
i'm doing i'm an expert that is this but
this excites me as well as this that
mattress i'm solid but
sometimes like i've taken three breaks
creating content three breaks creating
content one was at uh you know uh uh uh
20 000 subs one was at 455. one was at
1.5 and when was that 3.2 that we took a
break we took those three breaks
and i think sometimes just like johnny
carson fallon just like these guys got
to take a break and just go away and say
hey what are we going to do who's the
next guest what are we going to do with
this part what are we going to change up
are we going to add something new to the
show the same thing has got to happen
because if the product becomes the same
over and over again and you're not
recreating with the times changing so i
have a guy comes up to me i'm not going
to mention his name but you'll know who
this guy is we're having a conversation
together
and he says man my youtube channel
went from having we went from 200 000 to
a million and a half subs in 12 months
and we were getting millions on top of
millions of views
25 000 people would stay alive when i
was doing any kind of thing and i'm
lucky if i get 50 60 80. i said yeah i
said can you pull up those videos that
did very well he pulls up the videos i
said okay 5g
masks covet
no one cares about those three today
nobody does
and you still want to talk about 5g
masks and covet
once you go into a certain box like that
and you don't adapt quickly you're gone
so as content creators we have to
constantly recreate ourselves
if we don't you're like that person that
was a motivational speaker in the 60s
and 70s and 80s and still saying the
same message from 60s 70s 80s nobody
cares today they respect you
you got to kind of adjust or else you're
going to be left behind yeah sometimes i
feel like i lose that sharpness though
after so many years when you don't have
that same level of focus and that same
drive as you did when it was new and
because of that you have a harder time
adapting true but you're not 72.
that's true you're young how old are you
you're 32. you're 32 years old like you
you know like you're like
just so you know like your next 20 years
is
you're you're like
the next 20 years you're gonna do
a hundred times what you did the last 10
years it's not even close so you mean to
tell me i'm gonna wake up one day i'm 22
32 years old i got a channel that's got
4 million subs another one that's got
880. i've got a few billion online views
i'm everywhere
you know i'm respected people calling me
from i have a good net worth i've done
well for myself i have a voice that's
heard by tens of millions of people
what do i now want to do with this voice
i will tell you
if it's just subs you'll eventually get
bored but if i want to do xyz with this
it'll excite the hell out of you yeah i
don't know
for me when i was working as a real
estate agent i was always looking up to
people on youtube and so for me that had
always been a dream when i started
making videos i had so much fun
and instantly i knew that like this is
it i just had a gut feeling that this
was my purpose for the time and that was
after about seven to eight years working
as a real estate agent i'll be
approaching six years now on youtube and
i feel like there's that seven year sort
of
itch where i'm like what what's next for
me what's the next challenge
um and that's where i'm struggling i
think you're gonna be all right i think
you're gonna be all right i think you're
it's a very normal thing you're going
how long you've been married uh getting
married in probably a year and a half
two years so you're not married yet
you're not yet right you're gonna go
through as well when you get married
it's gonna happen you're gonna be at
your seventh year
marriage and you're gonna be like let me
tell you man it's all about the kids
it's all about this i feel like we don't
go on dates anymore
almost everything you do in life you're
gonna hit plateaus
you know half the battle
isn't
hitting those plateaus
plateaus are inevitable like working out
i used to work out to impress girls i
don't work out today to impress girls my
desire to work out today is to be able
to have energy enough to run the
businesses
and
to be able to wrestle with my four kids
and spend time and have time with my
wife you know and stay healthy i want to
be able to live a good amount of time to
you know witness these things so the
evolution of working out changes the
evolution of marriage changes the
evolution of health and eating changes
the evolution of consuming content
changes i don't read books i read today
that i did 20 years ago just because
somebody recommended it if you send me a
book 15 years ago i would read it i
don't read a book today if you send it
to me i read books i want to read today
i don't read books because you tell me
to read the book so for example say if i
meet a guy and they say you got to read
this book his credibility score for me
is zero because i don't know him or his
credibility scores are two i'm not
reading that book now let's just say you
say to me pat
the best book i've ever read
on content creation ever
i've never read a book better than this
if you wreck you think i'm going to read
that book of course because your
credibility score is a 10 when it comes
down to this world yeah pat just read
this book so so i evolved on what i
consumed i evolved with what books i
read i evolved with how i wanted to
spend my time i evolved with who i
wanted to be friends with i had friends
in my life well eventually i'm just
sitting there i'm like
i don't even know why i'm doing this why
am i even picking up these calls every
time i talk to you're complaining about
two of your friends and an ex everything
is complaining how can i help you i
can't help you so content
is the same as well you eventually kind
of have to ask yourself why
am i creating content you ever read the
book the story of david letterman and uh
uh jay leno i have it must read okay
must read deal i'll read it but you know
why though because it's about content
creation okay
you know david letterman and jay leno
were fighting to get johnny carson's uh
position okay it's an older book but
when you read this book you'll see the
struggles both of them went when jay
leno ends up getting johnny's time
breaks david letterman's heart because
it was david letterman's dream to get
johnny carson's time
and he was the better comedian
jay leno was a hard to work a comedian
david letterman was a natural comedian
so
then
you have to see the negotiation you'll
be fascinated by this but david gets a
different job i think it's cbs jay gets
johnny's side the first four years david
letterman wins and is number one for
four years do you know after the fourth
year david letterman never once bj leno
because jay leno was a harder worker on
finding ways to improve and david was
just natural sometimes natural people
don't improve they just rely too much on
their on their natural abilities
sometimes people that are not naturally
funny have to work harder to be funny
but that ability to work hard and figure
things out gives them an edge long term
so but i think you'll enjoy that book
especially at the stage that you're on
do you have any other advice in terms of
finding that passion for you yeah that's
a little longer
i read a book called leaderless
revolution okay leaderless revolution
written by british diplomat don't
recommend the book by the way i'm just
telling you i read this book so it's not
worth reading but there's a part he
talks about so a leader less revolution
leader like that mosquito really likes
you by the way
it's like a little nap leader less
revolution so leader less revolution he
says there's three things that drive
people
and you got to make a list and figure
this out he says make a list of what
you love
what bothers you what you hate
so you make a list of those three things
what you love and you'll say i love my
wife
i love my mom
i love real estate i love this i love
that what bothers you what bothers me is
when people are late
what bothers me is when people da da da
da what do you hate oh i hate bullies
i hate manipulators like that's true
right and then there's a quote that says
whatever you don't hate you'll learn to
tolerate
right whatever you don't hate you learn
to tolerate most people just don't like
their jobs they don't hate it so they'll
tolerate it yeah most people don't hate
their financial situation they just
don't like it if you don't like it
you'll tolerate it if you don't if you
hate it you ain't gonna tolerate it
you're gonna do you can do something
about it so
at this phase of wanting to recreate
oneself
it won't happen logically i'm right now
working with a penguin portfolio we're
writing a
book specifically on business plans
and one of the elements about writing
the business plan when i was presenting
it to adrian from from uh portfolio was
i said listen
what's the missing lincoln business
plans why do
90 of people that write a business plan
in december last week of december never
look at that thing again after february
because that entire business plan was
stemmed on what logic i'm going to do
this much in the first quarter that much
in the second quarter i'm going to buy
this office i'm going to open up this
i'm going to get this license i'm going
to take this course i'm going to take
this who gives a [ __ ]
all of that stuff is logic logic logic
logic logic
logical stories are boring no one
watches a lot right now i'm having my
kids watch derek jeter's documentary you
know what my oldest son says he says dad
can i watch derek jeter's documentary in
a movie format i said they don't have it
yet i said i much prefer watching a
derek jeter documentary captain on a
movie format than documentary because
documentary is boring the movie is what
entertaining he's able to consume it
more so what does that really mean your
business plan needs to also have
emotions attached to it what's emotion
okay so emotion could be enemy
is emotional
what enemy do you have that produces
emotion you ever made a list of 10
things people ever said to you that
really hurt and just kind of mess you up
a little bit you ever heard uh made a
list of 10 things people said that
really
felt very good the compliment like
genuine that you truly believe that
you're like you know my dad once and
said this to me till today i remember
this and i made a very big impact on my
life right it's emotional but enemy is a
driver
you know
jordan look for enemies kobe look for
enemies brady look for enemies it
produces something right
sometimes uh if i want to get uh one of
our guys in a company to move it's my
job to find an enemy for them it's your
job as a father for your kids to
sometimes find an enemy that brings out
the best in them because the best
positive distraction in life
is when you're in the pursuit of
something and you got a target that
you're going after maybe there's a
little bit of enemy behind it so again
less skill more will
less
you know competition more enemy less you
know who we need to hire next more
culture
less you know what our
business plan is more mission statement
less about you know what numbers we're
going to put up and write the business
plan more what is the vision so it's
more on the emotion side
and tapping on that emotional side when
all of a sudden
you'll feel it by the way when all of a
sudden you're like your eyes change
you know how you talk to somebody
in three different seasons of their
lives and you look at their eyes and you
say this person's uh defeated right now
huh
and you look at their eyes you're like
this person's very curious right now and
hungry
and you look at their eyes
my gosh this guy's so focused what the
hell is going on with those eyes
that's telling a story okay eyes is a
reflection of where we are here
this produces this
if this is clear people are going to
tell this yeah so what is this
logic no it's only emotion this is only
emotion this is not logic this is logic
this is emotion so if we can tap into
that that's when we start like even if
you started youtube channel there was a
reason behind it you know it was more
emotional it wasn't logical right so
that's the part we got to tap but we got
to go back and you know one time big
papi went on a streak of not hitting
home runs for like a couple hundred at
bats and he was like he was like this
and the coach takes him in and says look
at your swing when you hit 50-something
home runs and look at this swing you're
so tight you're so worried about
striking out he says just play loose
just open up a little bit play loose
just swing like you're dancing just
start dancing again you know sometimes
we play too tight and you're tight you
throw the ball
you know you fumble a video you you
fumble the ball versus you just gotta
dance sometimes we we put too much
pressure of performing and crushing it
and killing it and competing that we
forget to dance
all of those unfortunately are things
that are reminders and sometimes we are
not reminded of those things we need to
be
recalibrated every once in a while this
might sound silly how did you become
such a good talker
how do i become very fluid in the way
people speak yeah your emotion your
annotations everything about the way you
speak i'm listening to this and it's
very captivating
it's easy to see how you could motivate
somebody you know stumble over your
words much nothing guys i got a bad
accent you know my grammar if you if you
go back and write it out if you
transcribe what i said in this video
today and give it to an english teacher
they'll go like this entire time
i understand what you're saying and i
appreciate it what i will tell you is
the following here's what i will say now
and i'm not uh
being super humble about it oh thanks
guys but let me tell you i'm just a
regular guy
um
you know every every once in a while
in life
you're all of a sudden gonna realize
you're very very good in an area
okay
so
for me
my biggest strength is i'm extremely
curious
i'm so curious like i want to know i
want to know
why they do what they do i want to know
why they set up certain things the way
they do i want to know why they made a
decision that they made yesterday was a
big day in america you saw it all over
the news what happened with the fbi why
do they do that i want to know why
what's the motive behind it so the level
of curiosity
is what gets me in
but since i was a kid i've been telling
stories since i was a kid the first
company i ever incorporated was called
the story builders i love stories i
think stories move people
and you know if that's a gift of telling
stories
you know that's my ability to be able to
tell that story i i
i have to be in it so i i go into the
story i'm curious about the story but i
would say that's probably one of my
strengths got it what are your thoughts
on andrew tate i think he's a stud i
think he's scaring the crap out of a lot
of people
um
again i've never spent time with this
guy we both follow each other i like his
style you know we
uh if i would have gone a different
route i would have gone to tate route i
just chose a different route to go
uh i think he's making a lot of great
arguments that's pissing people off i
think he's pressing on a button and not
slowing down like he goes like this he
gets irritated the average person stops
doing that
tape goes like this you get irritated he
goes like this and he goes like this and
he goes like this yeah are you not gonna
stop that's tate so you would i would
have loved to have seen how tate was at
eight years old that's what i would have
known to see that and my curiosity would
have been more about his dad and his mom
dynamics because obviously his dad was a
very strong personality man
and some of the stories of what happened
with his life but a lot of content
creators right now are envious of the
guy of what he's doing and they want to
say well he's running this uh affiliate
marketing thing and you know he's
running this
uh uh scam and he's doing this he's
listen he's selling an online course
something many people have done he's
just doing it at a bigger scale than
others today but here's the reality of
it with tate
the biggest challenge he's gonna have is
what
how much can the world consume that
content before they get over it is it a
one year thing is it a three year thing
is it a five or ten year
i think
he's not going away for a while
i think he is very attractive i think
he's very entertaining i think he's also
a great storyteller i think he makes
very good points i think he is
multi-dimensional he doesn't just talk
about dating he talks about politics he
talks about religion he talks about
finance he'll talk about sports he'll
talk about fighting
when you're that multi-dimensional you
can be in any room and you can be
interesting most people are not very
multi-dimensional if you were actually
to sit there
and take the top 20 content creators who
are out there going viral and you were
to say who are multi-dimensional tate's
on that list logan paulo's
multi-dimensional
you know you got you don't have that
many people that are that
multi-dimensional so uh so it's not
and by the way this is the important
part to realize that a lot of people are
saying you think many people are going
to model after him
no tate is not duplicatable
he's not a duplicatable guy it's not
like a here's a format you start a
youtube channel you talk about this you
go google and you search for titles then
you make listicles top 10 reasons why
women shouldn't date
men without good mothers you know
top 10 reasons why there's seven
mistakes why is six keys to this so you
do 200 those videos yeah and then you're
like okay now what do i do
tayden doesn't need the seven keys to
whatever he's just that interesting and
entertaining
that also bleeds over to cancel culture
and i know you have
very firm thoughts on that could you
explain some of those thoughts and the
direction we're headed in terms of this
mob mentality of ganging up on people if
they say or do something that might be
incorrect
so okay so what's the what's the smarter
thing to do let's process that right
if if you want to live a peaceful life
don't model after
jake paul don't model after connor
or trump or tate or i don't know what
other name you want to add to that list
don't model after them okay
because if you can't handle hate it's
not for you okay
there's got to be an itch where you're
yearning for that
you're kind of like you like a good
fight like you like to get into the ring
and get a little dirty and get you know
people to say stuff about you there's a
part of those guys that like that right
are you surprised that trump is getting
canceled surprised not not is the right
thing sure surprise is a different
question are you surprised he's getting
cancer are you surprised people are
hating on tate are you surprised people
get upset at dana white are you
surprised people get upset at jake paul
are you are you surprised none of us
should be surprised because they're in
your face and they're not even surprised
if they're surprised they're naive and
they're not naive so they know this is
going to be happening right right so for
me that's that part now is it right to
cancel
i think what does cancel culture really
mean it means envy it means you're
afraid it means you're jealous it means
you
you know you wish you could be like them
you wish you could talk like them and
they're saying something that's really
offending you so your only way to beat
them is to silence them that's a very
cowardly way of competing you know the
way you compete is you compete the
reason why muhammad ali has as much
respect as yet is because he fought
everybody at their peak so everybody
respects ali he's got six losses i don't
know six or eight losses he fought
people at their peak and he would show
up and fight he never turned down a
fight right you know the other day dana
white gave a great compliment to uh
bisping i don't know if you've seen
bisping's documentary oh my god it's an
incredible documentary i watched it on a
flight back from monaco two weeks ago
and dana white says there's a lot of
guys in ufc that i call
and they'll say things like this well
dana why are you calling me now you know
the fight is in two weeks i need six
weeks to be ready for camp
he says there's one thing about bisping
i've never called bisping and he ever
complained about the fact that he wasn't
ready for a fight he says that's why i
respect bisping so much right so there
is this element of some of these guys
that are ready to go and you know
compete but
most people don't like that and i think
that's not going away anytime soon i
don't think it's a new thing i think
that's going to be on for a very long
time and what about you are you nervous
because you mentioned earlier that
you're starting to talk a little bit
more about politics about being canceled
or saying something that maybe the the
mob doesn't agree with so so what is the
mistake the mistake is on the following
the mistake is speaking in certainties
certainties like for example alex jones
right now going through the issue that
he's going through right what is really
the problem what is the problem with
alex jones did alex jones say anything
that anybody else said no he spoke in
what i know for a fact this is what's
going on
i know it i'm telling you i have people
on the inside you can't talk like that
you can't talk like that's but that's
certainty that's a little too certain
where all you have to do is the
following
i don't know
what if it's this
maybe if it's this
maybe it's that i have no clue but what
if you are certain
there's a difference but there's there's
there's a difference he was not certain
though yeah so as long as you are
certain about something it's okay for
example a lot of people i agree a lot of
people can
make something out to be a certainty
even though but here's the part you're
certain about what though what are you
certain about what am i certain yeah
what are you certain about
5 times 5 is 25. okay i'm certain about
that too 100 we're on the same page what
else are you certain about
the earth is spherical okay there's
certain things that we can be certain
about okay if you're certain about
something you don't have all the
information in it's a little foolish to
do that that's the part where you get
people to come you become a target you
caused it yeah i know for a fact marky
crash is happening versus like the other
day i did something with dave ramsey and
i said listen
dave don't know if you're watching this
or not i think you may be wrong now he
may be right with real estate if
inventory is not going to be there he
may be right but i think he may be wrong
and here's why
so then there's reaction videos and
people say what i disagree with bet
david i disagree with ramsay no problem
but i'm telling you i didn't tell you
100 percent i said based on this data
here's what may be happening and you may
want to do your own due diligence people
get in trouble when they talk 100
percent certainty here's what happened
and you don't know four facts so it's
not really a concern of yours at all
zero no because
because it should be a concern of mine
if i
talk from an area that i'm 100 certain
something is happening without me
knowing okay you have to be and you got
to work on that even as a talent you got
to be like let me back up a little bit
on this message up maybe because there's
been times that i've also said here's
what i think is going on and i'm pretty
confident this is going on but even
pretty confident is what
it's not certain it's not certain so
it's that one little out
that some of these guys got to put that
they're not putting in there
and that gets them in trouble so i'm
gonna play this game and go do what i'm
doing because
i love it i can't stop talking about it
and i'm so totally fine when some people
pull me aside and say you disagree with
your position about that tell me why
which part of it i disagree with myself
sometimes but which part did you
disagree with when you set the following
this okay cool so what's your solution
tell me yours well i don't have one well
then don't debate it if you don't have a
suit i give you mine then give your
solution you're part of the problem as
well if you're not giving yourself i'm
giving you my solution what's yours
maybe you got a better one but until you
come up with your own solution don't
judge mine
give me a resolution that you got is
maybe better than mine now let's hash it
out let's debate it let's see if we can
find somewhere there so that's the part
also knowing how to
react to somebody that's confronting you
because the direction i'm going i'm
going to be confronted
and that's okay there's nothing wrong
with that but do you want to see him to
debate in something i want to see
we could see if we could debate
something i just got a quick question
for you as you're kind of moving into
the political talks do you ever worry
that's going to impact your business
because in some way you might be
alienating somebody who wants to do
business with you but because you said a
certain thing oh maybe i'm going to go
with the other guy so i want to kind of
give you
some perspective here i run an insurance
company so the insurance industry here's
why we were able to build the insurance
company that we built uh you're going to
be in vegas on friday night yeah you
should just come to the backstage shaq
will be i just want you to really just
want to come and see backstage what's
going on here oh my gosh yeah i just
want to see what's going on okay so
friday night you'll be with us and even
if you wanted to come see nelly nelly
will be thursday morning but friday
night is the main one to come in dressed
in black you know black tie even come
real nice you'll like it and you'll get
some good footage as well but what if i
offend somebody okay
so i go into insurance business i write
a book called the next perfect storm in
2011 2012.
not recommending you read it it's an
insurance book you're going to be bored
out of your mind but for the insurance
space it was a book that was written
that did very well and i talked about
what was going on in the marketplace
this is why i started my own insurance
company in in 2008 data came out saying
the average insurance agent in america
was a 56 year old white male
only 17 percent of agents were women
only okay
so i said ron paul and all four raised
six million dollars in myspace in 24
hours obama became a two-term president
with a one-term senator who was he to
become a president but he did it through
5 10 15 20 on facebook that meant
anybody can run the game has changed and
everybody was trying to get the hispanic
vote okay
so when you come to the conference
you'll see one thing we are 54 women and
51 52 hispanic
and the average agent is a 34 year old
so the average age in our company is a
34 year old hispanic female an anomaly
most of our company if you're hispanic
politically you may disagree with me
okay
but the way we have created our values
and principles in php is that you and i
can have disagreements but we can
respect each other have a conversation
together matter of fact i welcome it we
like it
we like a good discourse we like a good
debate
so now having said that
does that also get some people to say i
don't like the way this guy said this
this that yeah i don't want to do
business with them sure i probably lost
some business as well
but has it also flipped and brought some
more true believers that we know for a
fact that we're on the same page
absolutely and have some people been
able to consume the content and say even
though i disagree with this guy i like
the approach he takes i'd like to go
into business with them yes but to say
there is no risk i'd be naive saying
that 100 there's a risk do you have a
solution for california or something
that they could do differently i really
enjoy your california videos yeah i mean
you saw the the i did a video the other
day talking about if you're going to be
staying in california
you know that was that was great by the
way about buying the place in the valley
i mean you made this comparison of
buying an average house in the valley
what was it one 1.8 1.8 million dollars
how much you have to make
uh as either a single person or a couple
in order to comfortably afford that home
and it was insane insane how are you
going to do it how are you going to pull
that off so so here's here the whole
thing with california for me is i live
there 20 something years i love that
place
california is a place specifically
southern california i can drive with my
eyes closed and i'll know exactly where
to go because i know all the freeways i
drove a few hundred thousand miles when
i was
selling insurance policies going north
going south going east everywhere right
in l.a driving but california has um
a couple problems
with where they're at right now
people are not
politically getting involved and
fighting back and they're just sitting
there saying yes to it when you live in
a place that doesn't want to hear what
you have to say and it's their way or
the highway you have one of two choices
you either have to become so powerful
money-wise influence-wise where you can
fight back meet kevin try to do a little
bit you know he try to go out there and
do some stuff with that so you go out
there and impose yourself
or you you get behind somebody and you
say let me help him out dude you got to
go run we got to figure something out to
get him in there you're the right guy
for it let's get behind him let's
support somebody or
you sit there patiently saying maybe one
day they're going to change and last but
not least what you got to leave now you
say that to somebody from california
that doesn't want to leave they say
things like but that's cowardly i said
be careful saying that why you just call
your grandparents a coward
what do you mean
were your grandparents born in
california no why did they come here
well what does that have to do with
anything they're from mexico your
grandparents are cowards
man
how do you feel knowing your
grandparents were cowards they're not
cowards so why did they leave mexico
they should have stayed in mexico do you
know how conditions were in mexico do
you know how conditions are in
california
what do you think sure so what are you
supposed to do sit there you're in
nevada why are you not in santa monica
yeah you have 300 miles you come over
here this way you save yourself 13.3
what are you giving over there for 13.3
that you're seeing being improving are
you seeing things get better all right
yeah so you you would much rather come
300 miles this way
build it in a state that says you keep
the taxes do whatever you want to do
you've created jobs here you're happy
you know so california needs um
uh this mayor caruso is good on what
he's going to be doing hopefully i hear
he doesn't have a lot of support though
i thought when he was running yeah it
seems like he has a lot of great
policies he could bring a lot to the
table but it doesn't seem like he's he's
up the popular vote who says that to you
though pulse okay
and who comes up with those polls i'm
not sure okay so
but the point is like and who shows me
those polls there's only a few polls i
trust right i trust gallup you know for
the most part pew
it's a few polls there's only a few of
them okay fox news poll cnn poll msnbc
poll come on guys let's not get naive
here when they pitch it to us like oh
you're definitely not one-sided uh cnn
poll says 82 percent of america loves
the job joe biden is doing
right
you know fox news poll says three
percent of people support what joe biden
is doing
both of them are you know kind of so you
have to kind of take
for yourself but i would say the
following
if a
if some of the most influential people
in l.a
are starting to like this caruso guy
you know and the ones that are not are
the ones that fear that maybe there's
going to be a movement of guys like him
going out there making a change of
course that's going to be scary and they
have the bigger mic the existing
politicians have the bigger mic than the
ones that want to be the politicians the
existing politicians are united and they
don't want other ideas to come into
california but
it's it's it's foolish and it's naive
for californians to think california is
going to be great forever
you're you're naive you go study detroit
to see how detroit was the richest city
in the world and then all of a sudden
where is detroit today when's the last
time you said you're going to go
you know buy a house in detroit there's
a lot of opportunities but detroit's not
going to be the next la or new york
anytime soon so we don't think
la's ever going to lose at all because
it's la well nobody thought kmart was
going to go out of business you know
nobody thought lehman's brothers was
going to go out of business nobody
thought countrywide was going to go out
of business nobody thought a 330 billion
dollar woman was going to be bought out
by a chase for 1.9 billion nobody
thought woman was going to go out of
business just like nobody thinks
anything's going to happen to them but
to to have your first year we have a net
loss to population since 1851
that's 170 years
for you to have your first year ever
since inception
for you to lose people california what
first time i mean you got to realize
there is there's a lot to be said about
that now my understanding that was 2021
2021 yeah could that be a lot of people
moving after the pandemic okay so but
why are they leaving though i would say
more space uh and maybe taking time off
work has opened their mind up to
different opportunities i wouldn't have
left had it not been for the shutdown
and that for me because i had a bit
business working as a real estate agent
when you're going back i'm not
right so why not yeah but why are you
not going back i love it here that's the
point right so but here's the thing okay
so say a girl leaves you
okay
and she says i'm trying to find myself
i'm soul-searching
but babe i love you
okay if she comes back a year and a half
later knocking on your door saying
you're the love of my life guess what
maybe she was really soul-searching
okay
but if you leave california during kobe
because our friend here graham was
soul-searching and you go find a new
girl called nevada and you don't come
back you were not soul-searching you
found something better sure so sometimes
the scary part is being arrogant
thinking all of these people are gonna
come back and they don't miami go to
miami right now
if you come to miami uh um
property value
skyrocketed rent
up
homes were selling for 15 million
selling for 30 million selling for 5
million selling for 10 million people
moving there from citadel
you know goldman trading
you know singer all these guys that
moved from
dc
chicago new york did they move there
during kobe because they're going to go
back to new york how come they didn't go
back to new york
no when an arrogant guy says to follow
into a girl oh she'll come back she can
never live without me
oh buddy there's a lot of people in the
world that are better than you
california let me tell you keep staying
cocky like that until people realize you
know the whole thing we talk about
sheltering yeah you know how we said
it's not good to be sheltered because of
public schools and i said in every
society every city we are in a way
sheltered okay
so
california sheltered a lot of people
the pitch was a great pitch
nowhere in the world you're gonna have
better weather than this i mean look at
this the mountains the water the weather
the beach
this is the greatest place on the planet
so then 10 people started saying that a
thousand people started saying that a
hundred thousand people started saying
that now people are believing it until
they left and they're like the weather
is pretty good weather is pretty good
for vacation but did you take advantage
of weather every day no weather is
incredible at monaco do i want to live
there today no sure weather is great on
a lot of places in the world i don't
want to live there though how do you
think the return back to an office is
going to affect that because i've seen a
lot of employers asking their employees
to come back and there is a difference
in working remotely in something in
person in what way in a way where i
think in terms of creativity um
i i think there's there's a there's a
hive mindset that happens when you get
people together in a room that you just
can't recreate online or over zoom so
you're more for working in office than
working from home
oh yeah i mean there's and there's no
question about it it's like saying
taking a girl out on a dinner uh and you
say
hey uh
mary love to take you out on dinner i'm
gonna have uber eats deliver and i'm
gonna send you a nice bottle of wine
you have it over there but let's do it
on zoom and i'm gonna order the same
thing here and i'm just gonna look at
you through the camera you're so
beautiful babe can you give me your hand
let me give you your hand here through
zoom and let me do this what are we
talking about right i mean
again
this this and by the way here's what's
crazy about it watch this the same
people
that said
working remote
that's what we should do
you know what states they were
california
new york right dc
illinois who were also working remote
and then what happened when it backfired
on all these politicians
people said let me get this straight
you mean to tell me i can make 120
and i can leave chicago and go to
nashville i can leave new york go to
miami he's still going to pay me 120 i
can leave california and go to nevada
you're still going to pay me to 120.
you know what i support remote you're
right except i'm remotely leaving your
state
so the concept of working remote
backfired
on the people that shut down states
cities and supported it you're seeing a
lot of entrepreneurs nowadays look what
goldman just did so goldman originally
solomon is like you guys got to come
back nobody's coming back you guys got
to come back nobody's coming back
solomon just announced a month ago guess
what what quarterly reviews and annual
reviews are back why we can officially
document that your performance is bad
and we can fire you because before we
couldn't fire you because what if you
come back and you see xyz nope we're
bringing that back what's facebook
saying what's google saying what's
everybody else saying either come back
and improve your performance or you're
fired mo zuckerberg just said if you
don't improve your performance you're
fired what's going on with the market
amazon 180 this year so far so what
happened there this this remote thing is
a great idea
and it's solid but it's not effective
one of the best ways to gauge whether
companies are still using zoom or not is
through the stock it's very simple
four years ago
pre-pandemic
stock of zumba was seventy dollars
you know what it peaked at you remember
what happened yeah like that yeah
yeah
it went from 70 bucks to 500 500 600 700
some dollar amount like that you know
where it's at today a hundred dollars
yeah
so what does that mean if zoom went from
70 to 56 700 down to 120 what's it
saying what percentage is 70 on 120
yeah it grew how much in the last three
four years
so companies are no longer using zoom as
much as they did a year ago or a year
and a half ago and they're going away
from it so do you think though that's
going to bring a lot more people back to
those states i worry that people maybe
have gotten a little bit too confident
that they could take a remote job
work in another state where right now i
would not be surprised if companies
begin laying off people and they say hey
if you don't show up you don't have a
job everyone says well the job market is
good now but i think a year from now
might not be the case and people might
say well no no actually i'll go back nah
you're right i mean look data came out
today do you know
uh uh 0.26 of all homes in illinois
right now are in foreclosure is it uh
one in 385 that's the heist in america
0.26 now somebody may say well that's
not a big number
one in 385 homes in illinois right now
is in foreclosures the highest in
america today we haven't started that
yet obviously we're going to see what's
going to happen because at 300 percent
well last year when they were doing the
forgiveness and you know more banks
right now are saying don't worry about
it don't worry about making a payment
don't worry about making a payment
there's plenty of equity plenty of
equity eventually they're going to say
listen man you got to make a payment
okay this loan modification concept is
only there's a timeline too where you
eventually make a payment
that's going to happen
companies are going to go back realizing
i can't create a culture on zoom i can
only create culture on face-to-face you
know they're going to try to sell it to
their management and their management
some of them that fight it will be fired
and they'll go and take a nice severance
for three or six months and then they're
gonna have to go find a job that's gonna
ask them to work
face-to-face live and they're gonna say
i don't have any other choice you know
what i should have stayed at that last
company because the benefits was better
that is gonna come that movement will
take place
but if you lost those people to another
state and they realize another state
cost of living is lower they're probably
not coming back to your state
got it what are your thoughts about an
upcoming recession i mean obviously by
definition if you were to take your
series seven okay securities license and
the question comes up they showed us the
other day on finra
definition of recession of course yeah
if you're taking a serious seven exam
the right answer is two consecutive
quarters if i answer three i fail that
question i have to put two consecutive
quarters so we're officially in
recession
of where we are today
how bad is this going to get is going to
be predicated based on are we going to
do more bailouts if we do more bailouts
that money's going to roll to the top if
we're going to print more money it's
going to roll to the top
if we're going to do this inflation
reductionary whatever plan
the money is going gonna roll to the top
i mean here's what's crazy about myself
i've made millions of dollars in my life
but
2019 or 2019 i made more money than my
entire life
2020 made more money in my entire life
including 19 2021 made more money than
my entire life including 20 20 uh 2020
2022 so far made more money than all of
those years combined what happened with
these
money they printed they throw in the
market it rolls up guys like me are like
print more if you want to but it's not a
good thing
you know
the right solution today for us to
overcome the challenges we're facing
no one would win
white house if they ran the right
policies today the right policies that
america really needs would never win the
election today never it wouldn't be a
popular policy you need to run some
shitty policies to convince people that
you're going to give them something for
free to win today that's what's
unfortunately attractive today but if
somebody got up and said hey guys let me
tell you
uh here's what i'm running for i'm gonna
make sure our military gets stronger in
the area of
cyber warfare and bio warfare we're
gonna take our spending a little bit
more on that side
uh
we're going to do what we can with taxes
we're going to take some of these
resources and try to pay off our debt
and the next four years our goal is to
get some of our reduce some of our debt
and we all got to get to work so you're
not going to see me too much we all have
something we got to do you got to pull
your own little red wagon i got to do
the same and let's let's bring america
back to what it was before wait what do
you mean i don't have any policies
we need to take some policies off the
table we need to get to work that
wouldn't you would never win with that
you know what you would never win with
that so you know in regards to recession
you know i think it's a great time you
know you got to pay attention to what's
happening with inventory uh an sf 90
ferrari a year ago you would have
three of them in a market to buy today
there's 35 40 of them certain rookie
card uh
michael jordan was selling for 700 000 a
year and a half ago vegas dave and i
both of us said this is not going to go
any higher oh it's going to hit a
million bucks it's back down to 150 to
200 thousand dollars
card going from 700 000 to 150 that's
that's a 75 drop off you know
certain you know from october of 2021
i'm sure you've seen this one to today
october 2021 to today eight months
discount stores in america their sales
volume is up 71
sales is up 71 why are people going to
discount stores
and and they did a research to see that
top earners are showing up there before
than they did before they consider top
earner somebody that makes 80 000 or
more they didn't have this many people
making 80k or more going to the discount
stores they are today why are they going
what are they afraid of what are they
preparing for so
you know have we hit the part where
people have fully lost their optimism
where everything's going to be okay
we're not there yet have we hit the
fully paranoia no people are a little
suspicious
but no one's yet paranoid and no one's
yet scared so there is no scared
opportunities today people are still
greedy sure so how are you pivoting your
business right now
how am i pivoting through business right
now yeah
are you taking in any of this into
account in terms of your own strategy
absolutely i'm i'm i'm buying a couple
uh media brands today well-known media
brands today that i'm in negotiation
talks right now
that are being hit
by the market but they're a value
company two years ago they were a great
company but they can't afford it to this
i want to go buy them up a couple of
them i want to buy so again i know if i
buy them what i'm expert in doing
as an operator i'm going to increase the
value of that business whatever that
business is that we're talking to
investment wise right now there's many
things that there's still great
opportunities in
you know the other day we
met with a 140 000 square foot building
in
fort lauderdale where the company is
about to go public and they need to sell
that building it's a beautiful building
they just did a bunch of upgrades two
years ago spent 22 million dollars of
upgrades they bought the building 15
years ago for 58 million dollars
but
nowadays their people are working
remotely and they're like hey
this building we got to get rid of it to
take it off the balance sheet because
the new buyer private equity firm
doesn't want to see
that uh uh this debt is there well i can
buy that on pennies on a dollar or sit
on it realizing people are gonna go away
from this remote concept and they're
gonna need space again two years from
now buy that for 25 million sell it for
75 million or 100 million there's a lot
of opportunities today
uh for investment so but interest wise
you know i'm a collectible card guy i
like non-duplicatable assets
uh
non-duplicatable assets that they're
one-off or limited amount give us an
example for example like right now there
is a
mickey mantle sgc nine and a half being
auctioned off in heritage auctions just
last week a honest wagner baseball card
tt06 sgc2
sold for 7.2 million dollars this is not
a high quality graded card it's only a 2
out of 10.
that same exact card last year sold for
3.6 million
so went from 3.6
to 7.2 million
well this mickey mantle card that is on
heritage auctions right now if you
wanted to buy it's at 7.3 million it
broke the record there's 19 more days
left in this auction don't know when
this video is going to go live when it
goes live it could already be done or it
still could be going that card is
probably going to sell between 10 to 25
million dollars
okay
so why is that a valuable asset because
there's only four graded at that number
it's an sgc nine and a half and three
psa tens you can't reprint many of those
that's an asset that's non-duplicatable
so areas that people like for example
say the best private school in nevada
what's the best private school here
i've i don't know so let's just say do
you know what the private school best
private there one uh
in the with the football team yeah
football team it's just down the street
okay there's a great private school here
okay it says 35 grand a year and it's
where top earners want to live okay
if i buy a house around that area
people are moving from california here
arizona to here
if i get a house around that area that's
close to that private school
there's only 500 homes around that area
that's cream of the crop everybody that
moves here is probably going to want to
put their kids in the best private
school
that's a non-duplicatable asset
you're not going to be that close to
that best private school there's going
to be always a market for it right so
it's more strategically but there's
going to be a lot of stuff that's going
to be discounted and at the same time
you have to be ready that if they do go
into
quantitative easing more
you have to know that everything's going
to go up again pricing wise inflation
everything's going to go up again
quantitative tightening is the one
that's a little bit concerning i don't
know how long they're gonna last with
quantum quantitative tightening
you know where the idea is quantitative
easing because you got a ten thousand
dollar credit card we're increasing your
rate to fifteen thousand dollars
quantitative tightening you got a
fifteen thousand dollar credit card
they're gonna say we're lowering you to
ten thousand dollars every month they
want to take 95 billion off the table
you've seen the numbers 95 ish they want
to take off until it hits a trillion and
maybe they continue there's only one
other time they did this for a couple
months when they did a market just went
like this nobody has a clue what's going
to happen there's not like a case study
you know hey there's a new steroid out
you do this you're going to win mr
olympia but no one's ever tested it
before can you show me case studies on
50 other people that use it we've used
it on horses and cows what happened to
those horses and cows well 17 of them
died but their horses and cows are not
human beings you're going to be able to
make it you're going to be fine we have
no idea what quantitative typing is
going to do so there's a very
unpredictable era we're in today so just
as much as you're being aggressive about
it you have to be
um you have to have a touch of paranoia
today as well what non-duplicable assets
are you holding on to right now real
estate that you can't have
you know like
waterfront properties are non-duplicable
you can't build water from properties
it's just a waterfront property okay
real estate in a
freeway or a you know
section community that everybody wants
to be there because translation-based
location-based real estate is to me is
non-duplicable collectible cards is
non-duplicatable i'm not an nft guy some
people are nfts it's not what i
specialize in uh it's anything that i
can't have that there's one offs or two
offs or five offs or limited amount of
supply for it what's your most valuable
alternative investment like a sports
card or something like that
what would be a sports car today
no for you for me yeah what would yeah
what's the most valuable yeah sports
card or collectible i have right now
yeah i sold uh two of them
uh it was a record i sold and i'll tell
you what happened when i sold this card
this is exactly a mistake i made so i
bought these two hockey carts for 5 40.
18 months later i sold those two hockey
cards it was a record-breaking card ever
in the history of hockey i sold it two
for 2.2 million dollars in 18 months
okay
made nice money
one of the cars a guy bought six months
later he sold for three and a half
million dollars one of them
wow
i know jeez you should put it up yeah
you should actually show this
when i sold it for 1.29 million
six months later sold for three and a
half million dollars a winning rescue
card so i missed out on how much money
2.3 million dollars so oh my god look
how much money i missed out right
because that was a non-duplicable asset
one of the guys that tried to buy my
card was wayne gretzky he wanted to buy
his own card because there's only two
graded at that level i got a call from
bruce mcnall
i don't know if you know who bruce
mcnall is the former owner
of the la kings and the former owner of
the best honest wagner card in the world
that he bought with wayne gretzky at a
new york auction in 1994 i believe for
451 that's a 15 million car today i own
uh a high-end mickey mantle card
uh i own some high-end basketball cars i
got some stuff i got probably six to an
eight million dollar card collection
today that's awesome yeah where else are
you investing are you invested in stocks
cars index funds i'm in stock did you
say cars yeah not at all that's not my
space other guys are doing that i'm not
in cars
uh uh if i buy a nice car i'm driving it
the only the other day guy asked me if i
like cars like i'm interested in the sh
and the rolls-royce that the shah of
iran had i'll buy that
and i'll put it in the museum and never
drive it because i'm going to look at it
because i remember i was seven years old
when i went to the museum and i saw that
rolls-royce and i said one day i'm gonna
buy rolls royce if i ever buy that rolls
royce from his museum i'm gonna buy that
and i'm gonna put in my house because
there's a story behind it i drive an
f-150 shelby 770 horsepower every day
and i got a million out of ferrari in my
garage i never drive it and i'm in the
market to sell it right now so i don't
drive it i've driven a five or ten which
ferrari is that sf90 okay yeah it's a
nice one and it's not comfortable for me
i'm not comfortable in it but
you were asking a question about uh um
you said what do you invest stocks yes i
am in stocks he said cars i'm not in
cars majority of the money right now
that i have is going to go on businesses
that i'm going to operate or have
influence over that's what it's going to
go to okay that's where the investments
are going
can you share some numbers in terms of
like net worth or how much you you make
in a year it's not a public number but i
sold one of my insurance companies
uh
shy of you know it's a multi multi multi
nine figure check that was sold to
and i owned 83 percent of it and a lot
of it was cash
uh so i have that and have a big chunk
of stock in a company that's
uh
doing very very well and where it's at
so you know that's that part so you know
if you're asking if you're asking net
worth
you want to count paper or you want to
count cash
let's do both if you want to do cash
cashes
probably sitting on shy of 200 million
of cash right now right now where do you
keep it all
it's in my house i put
yeah but but uh what do i keep it i keep
it at my uh
advisors who manage my money i'm always
curious how they handle that amount of
money
because it's beyond any fdic amounts
it's like it's got to be treasuries and
no no no you put it with some of the
main guys on what they're doing so
you're talking the main guys are who
to talk about the big ones whoever they
are that's where your money is going to
be
you got morgan goldman you know you got
a few other ones are you going to put
your money in do you plan to leave an
inheritance so i have a relative of ours
in iran who
they they they were doctors and they
made a lot of money
and what they did is
they didn't wait till they die to give
the money to their kids because they
didn't want their kids to wait for them
to die
so they gave a chunk of the money they
had a meeting with their kids and they
said look
here's how much we're worth
here's how much we're giving you now so
you can enjoy it and not wait for us to
die and the other money that we're
keeping we're keeping it for ourselves
and that money is going to be given to
our grandkids but they're not going to
be able to touch it until they're 30.
but this is yours this is yours
this is ours and this is for our future
grandkids whatever's left that they
can't touch your third
the kids are like oh
cool
that's great because you know sometimes
kids are like well my dad's got six
million dollars and he's 82. okay
they're counting the dates like this
it's your dad you know you'd be amazed
how weird sometimes people are right so
um the way the way
my structure is going to be when it
comes out with the kids is you know
you're not going to know who's the most
responsible to later on it's not going
to be a model of everybody's going to
get money the same way that's not that's
not the model
it's going to be
whoever knows how to do the most with
the resources will be
you know given
more resources to handle and then later
on at the end of the day when i'm no
longer here and i'm dying plan is to get
a lot of the money go to them and
portions gonna go to
charity and then you know whatever other
things that i
i'm gonna be universities my aspirations
are gonna be different for the last 20
year run this 20-year run is going to be
busi business media this is the 20-year
run the last 20-year run is going to be
politics sports education so could a lot
of it go to a university that maybe we
start later on in a format that i want
to create
maybe
but that's what the format will be and
preferably
uh i would like the kids to either be
doing business together or to be doing
business with us but it'll be their
choice
and
there will be markers everything in our
family is based on
markers my kids take jiu jitsu every
stripe they get they get 10 bucks every
time they change the ball they get 100
bucks
every straight a they get they get 100
bucks every you know assignments they
finish everything has a scoring system
for them and they follow it on what to
do
so their mindset is to earn and the same
thing is going to happen when later on
they go to school and what they want to
do with it do you want to buy a house do
you want to start a business if you do
start a business i would preferably have
you not work with me for the first few
years i don't want you to work with me i
want to have a lot of contacts and i
want you to go work with one of my guys
you know you want to be a youtuber go
work for graham stefan and see how it is
for two years do you really want to do
that or not hey i want to go be a lawyer
go work for xyz and see how that is and
then come back because
it's better for you to get a flavor of
other people other businesses that you
work with and then to come and say that
i'd like to be in business with you
great or say that i don't want to be in
business with you i'm killing it awesome
either way i'm winning but the idea is
to figure out a way for you to
contribute to society is there anything
that you're afraid of the unknown
i am afraid of
letting down the 63 year old pbd
uh you know like the other day i was i
saw a video of my year and a half ago a
friend of mine sent an old video of me
when i was 21 22 years old and i'm
saying well you're from now i'm going to
make six figures and i'm gonna do this
and i'm looking at that video i'm like
man i'm so proud of that guy
because while he's saying that
he's still partying hardcore five six
nights a week but he's working his ass
off he's at vegas every other week
you'd come to vegas they had a pimps and
hoes uh party they would put you that's
what it was called that it was one of
the biggest parties of the year 15 000
people would show up and everybody would
go it was like a halloween dress-up you
can put pictures of it the ones that are
appropriate you can show but that's that
was me every other week i was partying
my tail off and then one day i said okay
no we're not doing this no more so i'm
proud of the decisions that guy made
the 22 year old pat made i'm very proud
of him for what he did i'm not where i'm
at today because of what i did the last
12 months and what i did today because
of what that 23 year old did 22 year old
25 year old dead
so i fear not reaching my capacity and i
fear not fulfilling
the vision that i have in place all
right so i had to step in here because i
had a question i wanted to ask uh how
much of your success do you attribute to
luck if any yeah so
that's that's you guys have heard a
hundred different people tell all the
stories here's all i'll tell you i think
i truly am the luckiest man alive
uh i've always thought i was the
luckiest guy you ask my wife she'll tell
you how many times i've been pulled over
and my license has been suspended two or
three times because i like speed but at
the same time like a cop will pull me
over one time my wife and i are in the
car i'm going 120 miles an hour in a 45
zone don't recommend it by the way but
i'm going in some victorville which is
not far from exactly yeah a couple hours
from here
yeah but so this guy catches me and he
pulls me over i mean that's like
120 and 45. it's not just in jail yeah
yeah they're throwing it in jail so he
paul's miori comes up
he says what are you doing
i said dude i was beating you what are
you talking about are you upset
he says
what i said are you upset you couldn't
catch up is that why you're upset
what's the matter with this i'm just
joking with you i was going 120 it was a
little too fast not gonna lie to you but
i bought a new car i wanted to show my
wife a little bit of this speed i went a
little too fast he says is he always
like this
sorry officer this is how he is all the
time i'm so sorry
it's like
can i trust that if i let you go
you're not going to drive fast again on
your way to vegas so i don't know if you
should trust it but i'm going to do my
best
the cop is confused
and he says
listen man slow down but you can go and
he let me go
nah he should have given me a ticket
okay i should have gotten a ticket that
day as fast as i was going but what is
that is that a form of recklessness no
is that a i feel like a smooth talking
maybe it's smooth talking but a part of
it is also you know i feel i'm a very
lucky man i feel i get lucky all the
time
but i also feel if you want to spend a
week with me and see how i work then you
will say this guy's not lucky
so if you come around and you you run
for a month and you're gonna say yeah
i'm good you know it'll be a certain
time like yeah guys i gotta go hit the
sack okay you guys i got two zooms to do
you guys do your thing
that's why what happens when this
happens like for me there is work after
the kids and the wife goes to sleep at
10 30.
i got two and a half hours to work right
there everyone's asleep
most people are you know doing hitting
the sack themselves i got a lot of time
right there so now i don't recommend
this for everybody but i think the
concept of luck is that when i bought
the wayne gretzky am i such a great
investor
no i got a call from a guy saying
there's these two great wayne gretzky
cards in a market guy needs cash
tomorrow do you have it yes you want to
send the money i send the guy tikrun
tikrun was right you just met secret a
minute ago he went to l.a met him about
psa we bought it at psa psa's president
showed up they said these two are legit
give them the money we gave them we
wired them the money took the card sold
it a year and a half later is that
because i'm brilliant i get credit for
the risk who the hell buys a hockey card
three years ago for four years ago for
whatever the amount was nobody's
spending that kind of money
okay i get credit for the risk but i got
also lucky to get that call if i don't
get that call i didn't find that i got
the call it's a big difference i think a
lot of that's mindset though is being
optimistic to look for those
opportunities in ways that other people
might disregard and i think a lot of
those let's say you lose money in
something i think people could say oh
man i'm unlucky because that happened
and if i had done this instead it
wouldn't have happened but i think a lot
of lucky people view that as maybe an
opportunity where what did i learn from
this okay it was it was a lesson and now
this is good that it happened because
now i'm not going to take this to the
next thing i think a lot of it is
just being optimistic i don't disagree
uh i don't disagree that a lot of it is
optimistic but
optimistic is one of them you gotta
somehow some way it's the art of being
in 50 different places at the same time
that's that's like if the market says
wait what
then weren't you just there didn't you
just do that what are you doing over
there what this is like
what the hell is going on there's so
many things that's going on like it's
the guys at five different places at the
same time if people are saying that in
the market about you
you're creating a lot of opportunities
that good things can happen to you now
let me tell you at the same time last
week three deals i wanted to go through
fell through didn't happen three deals i
wanted all these three deals didn't fall
through the week prior two deals didn't
fall through i got a pipeline up you
know 21 in my phone 21 major projects
right now that's pending that i want to
be able to do
are all of them going to close
no
are 50 i'm going to close probably not
this year are 25 gonna close this year
probably
so you're playing the odds game
and you're hoping some of them fall in
your favor but it's not always going to
happen yeah you know would you ever
consider running for public office and
if you could would you run for president
i would and i would make
a great president in my opinion
but i'm not born here so i cannot they
would need to change their life but if
you could you would do it
i would do it you think that law needs
to be changed uh
do i think that law needs to be changed
i mean so what you're trying to say is a
person that's born here
40 years old
35 is the age well let's say he's 40
years old
he's more qualified than a person that
was born somewhere else
and lived here for 45 years i don't i
don't see the logic behind it i think
it's a it's an older tradition type of
thing which i respect tradition no
problem
but if it's about
making progress and improving
i think eventually maybe not in my
lifetime but eventually they're going to
have to change that law
because what are you going to do if the
better talent is not born in america i
do think they have to do where you've
been here for 35 years
i do think they're nice and i'm not
qualified
i do think the number has to be somebody
that's been here for 35 years because it
can't be like hey china send a guy over
there to go there for nine years and go
run for office no so i do think
and maybe even
natural is 35
but if you came here from another
country maybe you have to have lived
here for 40 years maybe a bigger number
but i think eventually they'll do it i
just don't think it's going to be my i
agree with that i think there's so many
great people who maybe moved here as a
child
but they've they've grown up here and
they've been here forever it never made
sense couldn't you not technically no i
was born here oh i thought it was canada
no no no or actually born in florida
really yeah what part orlando wow yeah
cool very few people know that and by
the way you're uh getting pulled over
story i don't think i've ever told this
story before but i'm gonna say it
because it was it was on my mind 19 i
had just gotten a lotus elise and i had
finished a car meet in santa monica and
i was in a really good mood i just had a
great time and it was maybe 11 30
midnight and santa monica boulevard
going all the way up was empty and just
a good song came on the radio and i was
just in the zone and i just decided to
floor it and there was no one on the
road and i was probably going
i don't know
probably double the speed limit uh if
not slightly more and there was a car up
ahead and i thought okay i'm just going
to zoom around this car and i did and as
soon as i got back in front of the car
there was a police officer coming the
other way and i was going really fast so
i was thinking did he see me
if he did see me like i'm already going
so fast he's not gonna be able to catch
up to me so i look in the rear view
mirror and i see his lights turn on and
he's flipping around he got you and i
thought for a second i could outrun the
cops
and so i immediately downshifted i made
a right hand turn went down a side
street made a left made a right i was
trying to like zigzag through these side
streets because i'm thinking i'm going
so fast i had never gotten a speeding
ticket before and if he catches me going
this fast like what is he gonna do and
so maybe a minute goes by and i think i
lost him so i start slowing down and
then i see lights behind me and the cop
actually catches up to me and then i'm
at a point where i'm like i can't run
for i'm not going to run from the cops
he caught me you're not going to run
from the cop i'm not going to run for
the cops but up until that point i
thought maybe he just couldn't find me
great story
so
i see the lights behind me and he pulls
me over on like a random residential
street and i've never had this happen
but he yells from his from his megaphone
get out of the car step back uh he had
me sit down on the on the side he comes
up and he says what were you doing
uh were you trying to were you trying to
run away from us and i was honest i was
so scared because i had 19. i i was
completely honest and i just
yes i was going way too fast
i thought i could get away from you i i
panicked uh and i thought you were
really far back i've never gotten pulled
over i have a clean record i just
freaked out i didn't know what to do and
i thought maybe i could get away and
he says okay he goes back to his car he
gets my license and all that he's
probably gone for like 10 minutes in his
car and he comes back and he says okay
we're impounding the car and we're
taking you in tonight uh because you're
being arrested and i forget what he said
he said for reckless endangerment
exhibition of speed and like he put in
like an illegal lane change or something
like that and i think at that point i
just like started crying or there's like
where i froze up and i was like
i couldn't believe it and then i will
never forget he said that's what would
happen
if i wanted to be an [ __ ] tonight but
i'm not going to will you never speed
again and i said nope and he let me go
with a warning and i never sped again
what a story yeah i was always so
paranoid because i kept coming back to
that moment and just thinking how lucky
i got in that moment i never did it
again and jack knows i i never speed
really ever speed limit guy
he accelerates fast but i don't know but
i never reach this i don't think he like
pushes the speed though but now
accelerates good friends
so your parents you what values did they
teach you mom and dad oh gosh i don't i
don't know um
my mom was really caring so she was very
supportive emotionally and my dad was i
think a really hard worker so he always
valued like you know going into the
office
showing up making making a good
impression working hard my mom was very
she balanced that out i feel great
combination yeah that's cool they're
still married
no
no so they divorced when i was five got
it my mind divorced twice in 20 years so
they each by the way
got married my sister's born they got
divorced
remarried i'm born
14 years later they got divorced did
that have any impact on you them getting
a divorce yeah at first it did yeah
because you know
you want mom and dad to be living
together and you want to see them
together my dad was my best friend and
and to
be in a household when i don't see my
dad for a year and a half when i'm in
germany no question about it you know
but then in germany
you know i i don't know what it is to be
10
to 12 years old because i replaced his
role so i was forced to
be a leader earlier you have to have the
lens on of a man watching out for your
sister and your mom
so
it could have been a different kind of
an upbringing with my dad but here's the
thing values and principles my dad
taught the right values and principles
eventually i realized the best thing
they did to get a divorce
right decision they made you know to
uh
go about their business the way they did
but yeah at first it did and then later
on i'm like you know we got to figure
out a way to win and we did
yeah at first it did though yeah i think
for myself too i i don't think it did
quite affect me everyone asked that and
they're like oh dude that must have
really messed you up but i think when i
was five i had no real
conception of just what a relationship
looked like or what what that was about
and i just remember liking it because i
got two christmases two birthdays and i
saw both of my parents equally so like
half the week was mom half the week was
dad and they switched weeks and they
were good together were they were they
still as far as co-parents yeah yes so
they respected each other and yes one
didn't talk smack about the other one no
okay well mine was not like that yeah
they were both good smack talkers but
uh my dad would say no matter what your
mom says you gotta listen to her and my
mom would say you gotta listen to your
dad but it was a very competitive
environment because it's armenian and
assyrian
and uh it was great but again if i i'm
if i didn't go through that i'm not who
i am today trail it's a very weird
dynamic how life works yeah you know do
you have any questions for us
what's next for you that's what i'm
asking you yeah
i still don't know okay i i feel like
everything i've done so far in my life
it's it's a gut feeling like i just had
this gut feeling to get my real estate
license and pursue that i had a gut
feeling to do youtube and i followed
those passions and i don't know what the
next passion is and part of me is afraid
of finding it because things are going
so well right now and i feel like i'd
just be an idiot to take the gas off the
pedal right now for what i'm doing and
so it's i think that's i'm in that zone
too much now to think of something else
where i but in my heart i know there's
got to be something else so what we do
know is we do know you're getting
married in 18 months yep okay
we do know you're great at creating
content you know how to make money
we do know you don't drive fast you you
follow the speed yeah never be a race
car driver i think we are making
progress what do you think
i think we're making progress
this is a sport right it's a sport
you're an athlete i'm an athlete there's
a bunch of athletes in the sport that
are going through what they're going
through
and
sometimes when you win a championship
early on
you
kind of don't have the fight of a
championship and you got to go back and
see
why you got to come back and do it again
or take the approach in a different way
and sometimes when you don't win a
championship for a long time
you know you're sitting there saying do
i really have the goodies to win a
championship maybe i'm not good enough
so
but to each player it's a different
structure but at the end of the day
you're a very
worthy athlete in the content creation
world
and you've inspired a lot of people that
are kids growing up saying i want to be
like graham when i grow up you got to be
proud of that that's a big deal thanks
because they're going to watch you more
than they're going to i'm 43 i'm old to
them
you're 32. right you know you're still
closer to them so they're looking at
what you're doing
and it's impressive it's very impressive
i'll keep you posted yeah i'll let you
know what happens yeah but uh
yeah it i just have a feeling it'll
whatever's meant to be it'll be meant to
be
it's a great thing about life sometimes
you gotta let it happen right
thank you so much yo thank you i really
enjoyed this this was great
um
so friday yeah we're gonna have a good
time on the backstage you know you kind
of get an idea what's going on i'm
looking forward to that and then we'll
go from there just tell me a time and
i'm here yeah we'll give you all the
details okay we got to get them to pass
as well so we can get them set up we'll
take that we'll take care of that cool
this was great very much yes thank you
enjoyed it really appreciate it
alex you're the man
you